and i need evidence got it wait you
don't know what evidence ah right on yes
hit me next to my desk is a picture of a
female politician bella abzug is that
scary face funny hat gap tooth or bill
clinton's wife funny hat funny hat on
the back of it is a key taped to it and
then that opens my bottom drawer and my
desk get
it
what's happening sorry i lost it
you got bored in the middle of them
[Music]
oh [ __ ] that's funny okay okay
sometimes when i wipe
i'll wipe and i'll wipe and i'll wipe
and i'll wipe
a hundred times still poop still poop
let me check that
it's like i'm wiping a marker or
something
john ralphio
[Music]
what's your name again
elise yarpton elaine smarkins
[Laughter]
oh my god no
hey jennifer look what we can do
jennifer
jennifer
jeff
jennifer look we're look what we're
doing
oh really
jennifer he's actually in me
i got it i got it nice oh yeah i also
got some dude's briefcase
i believed in you buddy but you should
put that back
yeah how did you get this
well what
that is
[ __ ] hilarious you shattered the
lights you shattered it not only did you
hit the wall heads around it that's not
something that props can fix that's
gonna be a little harder to fix them
sorry i'm out
man i'm in love with you
because you're just like me
you're a dog
date me ann i'm single
[Laughter]
ron you're gonna construct the stage yes
ma'am
i really think we should try and involve
this talking dog
and will you go out on a date with me
you're the prettiest dog i've ever seen
damn remember when we had sex in the
gutter on rodney street i'll never
forget her dad
i'm gonna come over there and [ __ ] you
up
[Laughter]
leslie doesn't like to hear her mommy
talk about sex
no one wants to hear that why don't you
tell us about your escapades you little
minks
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
mr dwyer
were you aware
of funds for tennis court
that ms knope requested that was denied
by mr ron swanson that was later
approved
by ben wyatt
no
do you play tennis
i don't know
are you aware of what tennis is
yeah
what point comes after deuce
wipe
i'm gonna go to the bathroom and powder
my nose
amongst other things
if you know what i mean
dude is she gonna powder her vagina
i'm sorry
dude is she going to powder
[Laughter]
can we just get it on the next steak
okay okay
okay
[Laughter]
a vanilla chai latte for my young nubian
princess
step one
we buy into this club
step two we roll over to the club either
in your mercedes-benz which is gorgeous
or my pre-owned acura legend which is
all right
step three i dagger you on the dance
floor
just bounce bounce bounce
bounce
bounce bounce bounce bounce now
everybody's watching
i'm so sorry step three
i dagger you on that dance floor
and dress you with my eyes
until at last it's just me and you naked
on the dance floor
you're gonna throw up you're gonna smile
okay well we just have to work harder i
mean good news is we can call it a night
and get a super early start on our
door-to-door tomorrow
he's like are they gonna let me go with
that
okay well we just have to work hard
well we just have to work harder good
news
[Laughter]
no i'm not happy about this factory
explosion and nobody died
[Music]
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
you guys i'm sorry this is totally
unprofessional let's just keep going
then we'll come back to it
sorry dude i thought i put in park
and does this help this helps a lot
it's hard right mm-hmm
things are gonna
[Laughter]
[Music]
get like being left alone in a room
with two cameras and little people
things are gonna get better right
bananaman that's
close
where are we going
to your mother's butt
ah i think you make a right turn on uh
wait a minute my mother's butt
so uh maybe we should just write um
things down
go from there
will you do it because i don't know how
to write
print or
[Laughter]
aziz
who my name is annabelle vandercrank
from the memphis van der cranks and i
just about lose my head when the sun
falls down
on my
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i need my mustache glue
listen it was very cool if you'd asked
me to come here i'm uh
i'm excited yeah we are too so let's get
this street going
and go ahead
[ __ ] my pants on camera
check everyone loves a good comeback
story right
seabiscuit the mighty ducks robert
downey jr
uh rocky yes kim kardashian kim well wow
in the video she gets she gets come on
her back i think
[Laughter]
i don't mean this in any bad way
but have you ever made out with another
woman
why
because
from my analysis
i think you'd love it
you